It's usually comforting to break down
a complex task into small doable steps.
For instance,
build Tetris isn't a doable task so
let's try breaking it down a bit.
One of the sub-tasks of building Tetris
would be to draw the tetrominos.
Then we need to make
the tetrominos fall.
Another aspect would be to make it so
that the tetrominos rotate when
you press the left or right keys.
And another aspect of Tetris would be to
play a sound when a line in the field of
play is complete.
Especially if you're
newer to programming,
this might just look like breaking down
one impossible thing into a whole bunch
of little impossible things.
So, as lazy programmers,
what do we do when we come
across an impossible problem?
Well, of course, we go find a library
that just does this for us.
Actually, since there are a bunch
of capabilities that are often used
together in games,
we can usually find a game engine
that packages up a ton of libraries
into a whole system we can use.